hi and welcome to episode number 48 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I am Franciscan pony I'm here with my
colleague mark Mendel hey Mark how are
you doing I'm good thanks Francesca are
you doing pretty good pretty good a very
happy to be recording in a room with no
lights cuz we discussed last time that
someone broke the door yeah all summer
broke the lights yeah it's a very dark
room but yeah it's pretty romantic to be
honest so very happy today to have a
yeah very happy to have the first
Spaniard in the in the podcast she's in
sm vide machine is amid since I'm
nephrons it has a furnace it in Spanish
I know how to do that yeah and she's a
product manager in the cloud networking
team for Google cloud platform and we're
gonna be talking about basically all the
things you can do with the network and
why Google klappa from network is so
amazing yeah now it's a really great
shot I I know so little about like
creepy seeds and VPNs and other things
of that yeah sure that it's it's great
to sit down and talk to someone here
yeah that stuff is one of the episodes
where I learned the most basically cuz I
didn't have much of an idea of what you
could do with it I know TCP and UDP
that's pretty much it I know what they
mean you know what they mean good that's
good yeah like yeah then ask me so and
after that after the Ted will will have
the question of the week which is also
related to networking yeah actually that
was completely unintentional but it
actually works really well yeah it's
gonna be about network load balancers
and some weaker protocol's I had never
heard about so proxy protocol the proxy
protocol on how to use it on a network
load balancer grew Club perform but
before that we have the cool thing of
the week and as usual I think yeah it's
renamed the cool things of the week so
the first one is we we put a cable down
somewhere wind solar cable yeah it's a
really big cable of Internet goodness
take hours between Hong Kong and Los
Angeles this specific light cable
network and it is twelve thousand eight
hundred kilometers of cable that allows
you to send 100 20 terabytes Turbots
terabytes per second
so which is pre amazing yeah you can
seem a lot of Netflix over that yeah
yeah yeah you can you can stream the
netflix per second basically it is
pretty amazing so yeah that that's going
to help a lot on people that are doing
if you have a server in one in LA
another one in Hong Kong the connection
now is going to be pretty amazing yeah
on top of that there's a really great
article for our net users out there
there's a maintaining containerized
asp.net core apps with Cooper Nettie's I
quite like this one especially because
now that net core is open source you can
run it on Linux which is super cool
which means you can get it on all the
stuff that's on top of Linux including
ducker and in container orchestration so
it's a really cool a little article that
talks you through how to build ducker
containers you can actually use the
standard Microsoft net dokku container
can get off ducker hub and then how to
build your projects on top of that and
then finally get it into Cuban in
eastern container entrance yea it is
definitely checking it out also if you
have never tried you can actually run
windows in our container which is pretty
amazing that I yeah that's something
that if you're interested on Windows and
containers you should definitely check
it out I thought you were good you were
going to say that you especially like
this bus because it was written by
someone from our team mette I totally
miss that that is cool it is actually
we're in my method maybe we should
interview him to have a dotnet episode
we should we should do that game should
absolutely do that and we have one last
cool thing of the week which is that we
are hiring so Google klappa from we have
a pretty big team yep I gotta say and
we're hiring like crazy for basically
everything I got an executive Sales
Engineer solution architects engineers
but also technical leads and a can
executive now you said a connectech this
I think that also for marketing and
we're basically hiring for everything so
if you would like to work with us yeah
check it out we'll have a link to the
careers page show notes and in theory if
you come work on cloud you could one day
be on the podcast if you don't work on
cloud you could also be on the podcast
that's also true that is
that is fair yeah but yeah you could get
to get lunch with us regularly which is
actually pretty cool okay so I think
that it's time to go talk witness I
think so let's do that so I'm very happy
today to welcome our first Spanier to
the Google klappa from podcast she's in
sm bead and she's a product manager for
cloud networking hello eNOS how are you
doing I didn't correct audio very happy
to have you so we're gonna be talking
about many different things networking
is a very very wide topic but before we
get started well then you tell us a
little bit about you and what do you do
at Google sure so I've been you know
long-term technology person working in
networking so I've been doing a lot of
enterprise and career working from
access to it to backbone and I've been
transitioning to a public cloud on I'm
so excited to be now part of Google were
with building like one of the most
amazing infrastructures and products are
in in the planets cool so could you tell
us a little bit so from a very very high
point of view what is networking like
machines talking together to each other
but what what do you do with their
working really so yeah you have machines
and that's a good starting point but you
cannot do much unless you're able to
actually give them a channel talk so
networking is all about making that
communication efficient and flexible so
that you can actually build topology
that is allowing not only you know the
most primitive types of communication
machine-to-machine but you'll actually
able to build your multicast your
broadcast environments so it is a way of
providing the plumbing if you wish for
our four machines so that we can
actually build screecher applications on
top of them cool so I guess it sounds
like it's probably almost several
components to like networking there's
like the hardware side that runs in our
data center and then there's like the
software side the probably talked about
as well as gcp when we start hardware so
I'd what makes our stuff good like
what's what's what's so special about
the the network that we run on sure so
traditionally a networking husband has
been running in dedicated boxes and
everything was really about having
dedicated a six the dedicated every year
so it's very hard word oriented and that
built like in the last decades great
technology which was deployed on
premises was deployed you know at the
edge in the backbones and those those
machines you bridges routers load
balancers they kept evolving and of
course the requirements on performance
on functional capabilities yes are more
and more demanding but also as part of
that evolution in the last year it's
been very exciting on the transition
about being able to actually run those
in more not dedicated hardware but more
hardware that is used for any of the
computer functions today can actually be
used to be great networking equipment so
together with a train add to have a lot
more distributed environment because
what allows actually to have the
performances that you are not bottleneck
to a single box where you actually have
like great hardware to run it but then
you can start distributing those
functions and then you need a lot of
logic in order to do that and what it
makes Google infrastructure crate is
that is been investing on data center
which actually you know provide all that
distribution across the globe where you
are actually able to send your traffic
as needed and distribute it to the right
points closest to the applications where
it makes more sense for latency and for
performance and of course google has
been building on that to deploy the
front ends and the back end for all they
are certain you to run all the
infrastructure so liberating on that is
a awesome starting point for building
cloud functions so that is really there
I think the best asset of Google Cloud
is able to leverage that great
infrastructure and provide the secure
environment for users to be
their applications the same way that
Google has actually been their
infrastructure applications nice so you
you said two words and that I almost
understood at least I knew one of them
was a sick which we used before once
which it is application specific
integrated circuit you also said FPA ofp
a it's a it's similar is hard work
purpose-built for networking functions
where you actually do lookups for
packets ok anything you apply firewall
rules so it is really a very efficient
way of processing packets that it was
necessary really in the past in order to
provide good performance for networking
capabilities cool I was wondering if you
could discuss one of the every single
time someone talks about Google
networking there's always Jupiter that
comes out like that really cool and
powerful magic basically thing what what
is that exactly and why is it so
important so Jupiter is actually yes a
fabric that is that is really a
providing high capabilities in terms of
bandwidth on performance and it really
is built by having very flexible modules
that communicate with each other and
modularizing that I'm being able to to
scale it provides a way for
communicating data centers in a way that
we don't have bottlenecks in the network
so it is just basically a highly
scalable architecture for networking
just that yes they're like no that's
pretty amazing that the fact that the
the network is not the bottleneck that
is pretty impressive cool so it is
really impressive that we have all of
that amazing infrastructure to build
application on top by running on Google+
platform but from a more pragmatic allah
point of view what what can I do like if
I have my virtual machines right like my
virtual machines I just start them and
they can communicate to each other what
else should I do right so let me then
get started now that we've talked a
little bit about the infrastructure the
first thing that
Scannell your users can elaborate on the
infrastructure is the fact that that
networks global global mean we at Google
have our own backbone infrastructure
with the dedicated links so it is a all
numb network actually there's two of
them that are just dedicated for Google
to communicate their data center so
based on that users can build their son
boxes with a global scope which is very
unique in the in the industry because
you can have your private RFC 1918 space
which is the private IP space spanning
all around the globe so you can do very
unique things like having you know
database replication across regions or
providing things like global load
balancing which allows you to have your
back games distributed across regions
for redundancy purposes and we provide
some very unique technologies to have a
single bid for load balancing that you
can actually that it sends you be a
technology that we call any cuts to the
closest cluster where you have your
applications so that actually provides
you the best of both worlds are very
global scope while when you're actually
making a request it sets you to the
closest point for latency purposes so
the first thing is global second thing
is you start building your security on
top of that once you have decided what
you need to have your applications that
you need to make sure that they're
secure and in order for them to make
secure your build your firewalls on top
of that those are all networking
functions that are implemented going
back to the first part of the
conversation they are built at the host
level so truly truly distributed so that
they don't provide any bottlenecks to
your network while they're securing your
applications right at the point where
they where they live so that you can set
up your firewalls for how those
applications can communicate your user
interfaces to apply it at your network
level but when it actually gets applied
then it goes to the host
with your applications are living so
they get secured at that same point so
you have the joy global network you have
your firewalls built on top of that that
will give you your security then you
need to connect to the rest of your
application so most of the use cases
will involve having to transition
migrate from existing capabilities so
you need things like VPN which we fully
managed as well as a service in order to
connect securely with your own premises
and you can fill rate your environments
so it is really a great starting point
for building your sandbox and then on
top of that there's plenty of
applications that we can talk about but
that is kind of the topology plumbing
security aspect of your son box where
you can then you know yes just build
anything you need okay cool that sounds
great but I know we have a variety of
tools and products IPP ends you're
talking about load balancers but as well
as a whole bunch of other stuff that I
personally don't know a huge amount
about what they do so I'm gonna take
like a practical practical example so we
have a web server it wants to talk to
the outside internet that's great but it
also talks to a database may be hosted
on like a vm or something but we don't
want that database to be accessible to
the outside Internet how would I set
that up using our networking tools oh
that's that's a great example so first
you want to make sure that you really
don't have access to the internet from
the application so the BMS that they
don't have to and the first thing you
can do you can actually protect that
with different layers which is always a
good idea in verses you want to make
sure that you have firewall rules that
are actually not allowing for any
connections that are coming from the
outside to actually reach that machine
so we provide what we call stateful
firewall Sun which what it does is
really you set up a rule which applies
to the whole session so as soon as the
session request comes if it matches a
setup pattern
then you allow or deny and then if you
actually deny that session like there's
no more chances for any other following
a package of that session to actually
enter so that provides a very easy way
of setting up the the firewall so you
can set up at the networking level those
type of rules and again they get applied
to your house where your database are
living so it is as well very scalable
way of actually applying those the other
thing that you can actually do is
enforce that those a project actually
doesn't have the capability of having
VMs with external ip's at all so that
will be an enforcement not so much on
the user that is actually trying to
change the behavior but at the project
level so that regardless of withdrawal
someone is using the enforcement it is
done so I will be for the database and
then obviously for your front ends you
have the capabilities of pinning yet
specifically the port for the web
application specifically the ports that
you are trying to reach and if you're
using capabilities like HTTP load
balancing then we we provide a proxy
solution which again is the same that
Google uses for production so the front
ends are the same and there is very rich
capabilities for instance for those
protection in order to find patterns
that could be possible attacks for your
for your application so if you're using
Google's load balancing as a service you
get advantage by default by all those
rich capabilities that are already there
right so what you're saying is that if i
have if i have an instance if i have a
bunch of instances that are running my
web server just by putting a web load
balancer in front of them to facilitate
the access and share just one single IP
i'm also gaining that protection against
denial of service and these kind of
attacks that's correct those
capabilities are again the same that
apply to the external access
communication that happens for any of
the Google applications so I mean
leveraging on those existing
capabilities
great asset cool what about what about V
pcs I've heard about V pcs many times
and I'm almost sure it means virtual
private what is the sea I could have
that what is that well cloud buddies
we're toil and his private so it all
goes with the pantages so so I RVP see
something that good help what you were
talking what what is actually a VPC and
how good it help make our solution safer
so the bpc it's really you can think of
it again I use the term before but you
can think of it as the Sun box where you
are actually running your application so
if you as a user have your production
environment your production environment
is going to run in a private space you
don't want to expose it to the Internet
so those applications in your production
environment are going to be talking
across each other you have rules that
are going to define how they actually
communicate and you have your perimeter
define for those applications any
communication external then it's going
to be control again with firewall rules
so it gives you private space like in
the internet working it will be a
private IP space where you are mapping
your applications you running your
services while you are securing against
the outside outside world and there are
great ways of liberation of that sandbox
on that private IP applications when
you're actually working in Google
environment some of the enough for
instance access to Google services like
storage or big data or bigquery where
there is all the data ingestion and data
processing capabilities you can actually
access those from your VPC which is
again your private environment privately
as well so that when you're
communicating your were close to get
access to all the api's and service
capabilities that google offer think as
well you know about machine learning API
so you do that in a secure way
be a private communication so it's
really a way of building truly your
private cloud yeah well it is all butyl
eyes because it gives you the illusion
that you are running your own
infrastructure you run your own services
but what it does is of course gives you
all the flexibility of you need extra
capacity you don't really need to worry
about you know bringing new hardware
they give you the illusion that is all
your infrastructure you can actually
secure it and make sure that is not
accessible by anyone else gives you the
ls isolation with the rest of the 10
onset of course lives in google cloud
but then you have all day nice private
private capabilities now i'm going to
ask this question and I could be totally
wrong which is totally fine so this sub
networks relate to V pcs right so
there's some networks it will be if your
VP sees your sandbox then you carve out
IP space right working so it is the IP
range that is going to be used for IP
allocation for certain applications so
you just want to make sure that if you
run in let's say in your case you were
talking about web servers and you're
working you're talking about databases
you may want to have your web servers
having you know I piss allocated from a
specific space your databases having
applique p ranges from a different space
unless you actually grow with more
applications you want to have some way
of aggregating JP space to those because
it makes it so much easier to
communicate to those when you have a way
to aggregate how you refer to them in
the networking I guess then that means
that okay so yeah if you have like one
set of services or one application that
you just want to make sure will never
ever talk to like another set of
services or an application like a just a
very particular path through that's just
another layer of network security that
you can put in front of stuff that
that's that's correct and you know the
way it helps is again when you're
talking about which applications can
talk with your own premises
which applications can talk with each
other you usually express those policies
in terms of IP ranges so if you map your
applications to those IP ranges then it
makes sense to actually then express
those policies based on those IP ranges
and you can map it easily cool um
something very related to the IP ranges
and how you define rules on top of that
is you can also define rules on top of
labels right like you can say oh I'm
going to type all these virtual machines
with labels saying these are web servers
and then all of the others saying oh
these are I don't know like my sequel
instance is whatever and then you can
say web server cannot talk to all the
web servers because why good day is that
the same kind of the same power as IP
ranges do we have it just for
convenience or is there actually a
specific use case that we should keep in
mind yeah that's a very good question um
so we want to use us much flexibility as
possible when we're actually given the
user the policies in so the way they
actually express the communication rules
it could be with IP ranges but you can
use metadata in order to make it even
more flexible so the labels are metadata
that apply to a specific PMS so that
when you express who can talk with who
if you have more granularity that cannot
be expressed with IP ranges you still
have the possibility of doing that by
applying metadata to the specific
instances that you want to secure the
communication with so it gives you yet
another layer of flexibility on top of
the IP ranges on how you actually
express your policies nice cool so we
talked a lot about at Google Cloud
particularly like hybrid cloud like
officially like on prem with with cloud
providers Network Dean would seem like
that's a big part of that like making
sure we have secure communication
between your on-premise systems and what
we have running in a cloud what what do
we have that enables us to do that like
how would that work how does that how
does that happen yeah so there's
many different ways of communicating
with on premises usually when you're
communicating privately to UM premises
you want to have some security as well
so once you actually cross the internet
if you have certain applications living
in google cloud and you still have
certain applications that live on your
infrastructure and your premises once
you start communicating them you really
need to go through internet to build
that bridge so there are several
techniques one of the most popular is to
use ipsec tunnel so VPNs in order to to
provide that secure communication so we
offer completely managed VPN building on
top of IPSec that can connect your bb
see your son bomb so specifically your
son boxing to make sure this on your
application who can actually talk with
your own premises and now we provide the
capabilities of up to a to get per
second ipsec tunnels that can be
actually horizontally scale so that you
can actually build bandwidth on on top
of that there are other ways of
delivering that communication between on
prem and on google and there are many
applications these days as well like the
more modern applications they actually
have application level security see they
usually have ssl as part of their
application communication so some of the
users might decide that they don't need
the Transport Security and they use the
application instead doing that you can
just have a regular pill in agreement
with Google or you can actually if you
are a smaller user you can appear with
any career so that you don't actually
need to maintain your own asin and
there's you know there is a knock that
you need to maintain so pairing with
google comes with certain requirements
so for smaller users you just compared
with any career we have plenty of
agreements and have that communication
plane and then on top of that you can
either use AP seconds with
ugh or you can be a good application
secure and just communicate through up
through ssl we also have this thing
called cloud router I don't understand
what it does it seems to be too likely
related to what it is that we do here
like in terms of like talking about I'm
prime because it does it does do stuff
over cloud VPN but i like i said this
networking stuff confuses me so i'm very
happy here and i can ask really dumb
questions yeah so once you communicate
to our own premises you have certain
workloads that get represented by
prefixes in your v pc and then you have
certain applications that get
represented by prophecies in in your own
premises so in order for those two
prophecies to actually be able to reach
each other what do you mean by prefixes
IP IP ranges so in order for those IP
ranges to be able to reach each other
you need to set up routes and then you
need to say you know my AP range one
needs to be sent to my appearance too
and the other way around so you could
always hard code that and say like all
the traffic destiny to my appearance too
i'm going to send with the next hope
this tunnel then you're done but then
what happens if you didn't add on IP
range 3 then you need to go and remember
you need to configure another route
otherwise you wouldn't be able to
communicate so what cloud router
provides is dynamic advertisement of
those r out so then those can be seen
from on premises as reachable through
the tunnel so then you don't really need
to worry about reaching your
applications across so it is built with
BP capabilities so dynamic routing
protocol and then it allows you to have
a lot more automated way to communicate
in your environment cool cool so I have
one last question which is which is okay
so I just started I have my virtual
machines running I just started them and
I'm running whatever fortress or
something like that i have my my
database and
one single web server what is the first
thing I should take into account know
what is the resource that I should start
reading to make sure that what I'm doing
is not incredibly wrong and I'm going to
be hacked in less than a minute so you
want to set up just a simple p.m. into
your network to run application yes a
very simple setup so far saying you
start a vm you don't configure it with
public IP if you don't really have to so
just make it private when you configure
your vm you're going to have you know
your capability self-selecting whether
you want to actually allocate a public
IP or not you want to admit that it as
we talk if you want to set up specific
rules for that specific world that might
be this thing from others that being
your own sub network so you configure
those on your BM because then based on
that you can actually set up policies
that get associated to that then you
make it part of a subnetwork so your
subnet word is going to define from
which side p rains it gets allocated is
a private and you're pretty much set up
for your vm now what you need to do is
to start building your firewall rules on
top of that so what you're going to say
is now set that this specific p.m. can
only receive traffic from source 1111
because that is a trusted application
while all the rest I'll block so
actually by default we block all the
traffic run if you want to talk with
anyone you need to actually go and open
it up so that you can talk with your
application so you will build that fire
wall you can say apply only to this
label which is the metadata that you set
up in in your pm and at that point
you're pretty much up and running go uh
we are pretty much running out of time
yeah much surfing but is there anything
else that you would like to mention
something some topic that we have we may
have forgotten not really i think one of
the things that we're most proud of with
google networking is really they are I'm
in infrastructure that is sitting behind
so it is the performance the type of
throughput that we have for
communicating to BMS like for instance
within a cluster we can have up to 14
gigabit per second which is pretty
amazing the latency around we can reach
around 100 microseconds that is slightly
better than my Wi-Fi so it is in terms
of performance latency it is definitely
top class network and leveraging on that
then are all the policies that we talked
about so then it helps you to have the
the perception that you are just unique
in that infrastructure and then you are
just operating your own environment well
you are having all these amazing capable
it is and access to storage and you know
you need to spin a hundred more
instances you don't need to worry about
my more servers and then all the sudden
you'll get the same right capabilities
that you had in the first instance that
you will so I think this is the one of
the biggest assets of Google Cloud
that's what you were saying before
building on the shoulder of giants yeah
exact same topic again yet wonderful all
right well thank you eNOS thank you so
much for joining us we really appreciate
you taking the time to come and have a
chat with us no thank you thank you very
much thanks so much to Ennis and bid for
joining us today first of all i hope i
pronounced your name correctly and thank
you for all it was a great conversation
i'm definitely gonna get stuck into the
networking tools that we were talking
about today and looking at how i can
lock down all my services and my VMS and
everything else that i run inside the
cloud yeah i think that it really made
sense to have such an episode after the
cloud abuse cloud abuser was mainly
about yeah if you have issues with abuse
probably you're being hacked so this one
is dunk it hacked and this how to avoid
it so yeah very interesting lots of lots
of documentation so check the show notes
definitely there's going to be a lot of
links to cool things that you should
probably take into account if you are
the one responsible for security and you
work absolutely so to finish with the
episode we have one more network thing
which is the question of the week is it
coming from Luna it is coming from Luna
one of the one of the good people who
hang out on a slack channel for God
she's cool hello Luna so yeah she sent a
question that I did not understand much
about it but to be honest I actually
didn't know but ok so there's this thing
that some of you might know which is so
you have a request that an HTTP because
that goes through a proxy I'm sorry
throw a proxy to a load balancer and
when you get it the IP of the packet
that you receive actually if the the
origin is the load balancer not the
customer yet actually send you the
request but there's this thing that
allows you to know which what is the
actual origin which is included as a
product as a header in the request cool
and that is for HTTP but what about TCP
TCP does not have headers no no so how
do you do that so it's an interesting
one so say your classic example is
you're building a game or something like
you have a WebSocket connection or
something that has purely TCP base right
you're not doing HTTP but you want to
know where your originating IP addresses
from and again same issue right your
network load balancer is going to be the
one that's the IP you're going to say so
exactly like you would have like Syria
and X forwarded header with HTTP there's
a thing called a proxy protocol that is
built exactly for this so a proxy
protocol I'll let you will have in the
show notes you can read all about it but
it's basically a convenient way to
safely transport sort of connection
information across a TCP connection so I
can use that on my traditional TCP load
balancer so that's the interesting
question so we have a network load
balancer unfortunately it doesn't
support the park see protocol ok that's
the standard network load balancer which
is which is a regional load balancer but
we do have a TCP ssl load balancer oh
that's a load balancer that will
terminate nick's ssl connection which
you should be using because as i sell
good necessarily yeah it's good yeah and
not only is it not regional it is global
which is also great but one thing it
does do is it does support the proxy
article so if you want to be able to
send that information across it will do
that for you quite easily which is super
super super cool very nice yeah I was
raining the communication which we will
link from the show notes as usual and
yeah it looks like it's pretty simple so
yeah ice yeah it's really
straightforward to use you can even
update the proxy protocol header for the
proxy like right in the command line
tools or through the development council
as well so if that's information you
want to go send across use an SSL ssl
load balancer and its global which is
fantastic nice little do exactly what
you need ok so before we finish what are
you going to be doing are you traveling
somewhere I am traveling uh oh be at
connectech in Atlanta literally the day
after this episode as and then later in
the month I will be a gamer Khan in
Atlantic City cool yeah very nice I'll
be hanging out around here working on
videos and stuff like that and I will be
running office hours in the launch pad
which we should very quickly mention
it's a new space where you can come and
learn things about Google cloud platform
and Android and basically anything in
San Francisco so if you are a local come
check it out I'll be there on Tuesday
25th of October from 9am to 1pm so come
ask questions if you have any yeah if
you want to learn about go and cloud and
all the things yeah and after that of
course i'll be going to Brazil for go
for companies all right set up with that
got any new just for funk episodes
coming out yes I recorded it for the
third time in a row and the I think this
timing actually like that everywhere
yeah I'm editing so probably by the time
this episode is out there would be also
an other episode of just for funk out
right on time fantastic yep well
Francesca thank you so much for joining
me yet again this week thank you Mark
and thank you all for listening alright
then see you all next week
you